[Music]
you're standing at the ready inside the
goal when suddenly you feel an intense
itch on the back of your head we've all
experienced the annoyance of an
inconvenient itch but have you ever
pondered why we ditch in the first place
the average person experiences dozens of
individual itches each day they can be
triggered by all sorts of things
including allergic reactions dryness and
even some diseases and then there are
the mysterious ones that pop up for no
reason at all or just from talking about
itching you're scratching your head
right now aren't you anyhow let's take
one of the most common sources bug bites
when a mosquito bites you it releases a
compound into your body called an
anticoagulant that prevents your blood
from clotting that compound which we are
mildly allergic to triggers the release
of histamine a chemical that makes our
capillaries swell this enables increased
blood flow which helpfully accelerates
the body's immune response to this
perceived threat that explains the
swelling and it's the same reason pollen
can make your eyes puff up
histamine also activates the nerves
involved in inching which is why bug
bites make you scratch
but the Itchy sensation itself isn't yet
fully understood in fact much of what we
do know comes from studying the
mechanics of itching in mice researchers
have discovered that itch signals in
their skin are transmitted via a
subclass of the nerves that are
associated with pain these dedicated
nerves produce a molecule called
natriuretic polypeptide B which triggers
a signal that's carried up the spinal
cord to the brain where it creates the
feeling of an itch when we scratch the
action of our fingernails on the skin
causes a low-level pain signal that
overrides the itching sensation it's
almost like a distraction which creates
the sensation of relief button is there
actually an evolutionary purpose to the
itch or is it simply there to annoy us
the leading theory is that our skin has
evolved to be acutely aware of touch so
that we're equipped to deal with risks
from the outside world
think about it our automatic scratching
response would dislodge anything harmful
that's potentially lurking on our skin
like a harmful sting a biting insect or
the tendrils of a poisonous plant this
might explain why we don't feel itchy
inside our bodies like in our intestines
which is safe from these external
threats though imagine how maddening
that would be in some people glitches in
the pathways responsible for all of this
can cause excessive itching that can
actually harm their health one extreme
example is a psychological condition
called delusory parasitosis where people
believe their bodies are infested with
mites or fleas scurrying over and under
their skin making them itch incessantly
another phenomenon called phantom
itching can occur in patients who've had
amputations because this injury has so
severely damaged the nervous system it
confuses the body's normal nerve
signaling and creates sensations in
limbs that are no longer there
doctors are now finding ways to treat
managing anomalies in amputees mirrors
are used to reflect the remaining limb
which the patient scratches that creates
an illusion that tricks the brain into
thinking the imaginary itch has been
satisfied oddly enough that actually
works researchers are also searching for
the genes involved in inching and
developing treatments to try and block
the pathway of an itch in extreme cases
if having an unscratched feels
like your own personal hell
Dante agreed the italian poet wrote
about a section of Hell where people
were punished by being left in pits to
itch for all eternity
[Music]